nate it's time to escape to the sahara
desert the north end of the strip has a
new oasis and rocky is there live to
show us all that the azilo ultra pool
has to offer hey rocky
hey mercedes yes do you guys think that
i'm somewhere in morocco right now am i
giving the vibe am i setting the tone
and this is your place you're the
director of day day life nightlife and
entertainment here at the sahara that's
you're busy that's a big job yes it is
it is and uh we've been very busy
the last few months getting this venue
up and running you know we're very
excited with the azila ultra pool uh
here at sahara it's las vegas most
immersed uh
you know ultra pool pull
we're offering an intimate
poolside experience with sexy moroccan
decor lush greens and of course an
alluring atmosphere where the music
elevates you know everyone's senses as
soon as you enter right here in our
venue you're greeted by our big led
screen right on the facade of you know
of the venue which is probably one of
the largest led screens ever built in
entertainment venue about over 10 000
square foot 240 foot uh long with um you
know about 40 foot high in addition to
that we have amenities to offer for our
guests starting with our vip cabanas
our bungalows and of course you know
daybeds right on the water with the lily
pads as well oh my gosh it is beautiful
here and right now you're offering a
very relaxing experience but coming up
in the coming months we have a whole
latin music spread correct that is
correct you know we're working really
hard right now
to to program um especially for next
year um i know we open on labor day
weekend which was a little bit late in
the season but our main focus will be
next year all right well i'm so excited
coming up later in the show we're going
to look at all the food and beverage
that they have to offer here as well
i'll send it back to you guys looks like
fun thank you rocky we'll check in with
you later on in the hour jason